thank you if you've been a producer long
enough and you've been responsible for a
consistently high quality emotion
picture production the academy's board
of governors might consider you for the
thalburg award the thalburg to a
producer is what the nobel prize is to a
chemist the pulitzer to a novelist and
the kentucky derby to a horse owner
tonight a man who has already been on
with the thalburg award were presented
ladies and gentlemen
stanley kramer
uh it's said
that louis b mayer once told
irving thalberg
irving
new york doesn't like artistic films
and thohlberg replied lb
it isn't that new york doesn't like
artistic films
they don't like artistic films that
don't make money
now fallberg was right to say that
because a picture does make money
it can't have artistic quality is a
cliche
the gap between box office success and
artistic success
narrows each year
which speaks well i think for audiences
and filmmakers
this year
a distinguished contributor to the
narrowing of that gap is the worthy
recipient of the thorberg award
consider
a few of the films that have come from
his sound stages to your theaters
some like it hot
the magnificent seven the apartment west
side story
fiddler on the roof
in the heat of the night
midway
it's quite a list
the fallberg legend is our buffer
against
delusions of adequacy
and the production of such a work
is the winner such works is the winner
of the irving thorberg memorial award
for 1978
mr walter mirrish
thank you stanley
even though i'm one of the few people
here tonight who's not been sweating out
the opening of an envelope
i assure you
this is one of the most deeply felt
moments of my life
from the time i produce my first motion
picture
i've always considered this award
to be the highest recognition that can
come to a member of my profession
so thanks to the board of governors and
the membership of the academy
they have enriched my life beyond
description
i also want to acknowledge the enormous
contributions both to my work
and whatever success i have had at it
that have been made by my brother marvin
and my late brother harold
they have been my indispensable
collaborators from the very beginning
and then my thanks go to all the
talented producers directors writers
actors actresses jesse and countless
others
who have been a part
of all the mirish company films
they all share this honor with me
these are exciting times for us
filmmakers
there is now the widest diversity of
subject matter available to us
technical excellence is at an all-time
high
creative young people are entering our
profession in all areas
and audience interest continues to grow
i am stimulated by my work as never
before
i love this magnificent
aggravating fascinating art industry
and i pledge to do my utmost
in the coming years
and in future films
to continue to merit your approval thank
you
you